قرات الكثير عن
وانا بالتاكيد اتبع الاجل العلميه فاذا ما
كان الذكاء الاصطناعي
يتجاوز القدره العقل البشري
فكيف نتعايش معه اذا ما كان الذكاء
الاصطناعي
اذا
تجاوز حتى قدراتي وقوتي البشر تسليمتر
تهديدا لهم وهذه مشكله كبيره اما من ذلك
فعلينا ان نركز بشكل اكبر على التهديدات
النوويه او التهديدات الوجوديه التي
زادت خطورتها
[موسيقى]
ما فيما يخص الذكاء الاصطناعي فكلنا ان
نعرف بان هي مساله مقلقه للحكومات وكذلك
للانسانيه انا عضو في المجلس
وليس لدينا اي مصالحه وفقط ان نريد ان
تعيش الاجيال المستقبليه حياه جيده
وبذلك فنحن سعداء جدا
للمشاركه في هذا الحدث
ونحن نقول ان هناك فشل في القياده الدوليه
فعندما نفشل علينا
نذكرهم بفشلهم والان عليكم اتخاذ قرارات
افضل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]